as many of you know I'm Patty Brennan
for seven years I have enjoyed being the
director of the National Library of
Medicine and working with the over 1600
women and men whose efforts come
together to produce the Fantastic
services and products at the National
Library of Medicine brings to the world
today I come to you to say goodbye as of
September the 30th I will be retiring
from federal service and from the
National Library of Medicine
in good health and Great Hopes I move
into the next stage of my life and I
will take with me many of the lessons
that were part of my time at the
National Library of Medicine
the lessons include learning what it
takes to deliver to science and Society
our fantastic bibliographic and
literature resources our molecular and
genomic databases clinical trials
information and advice for people who
are trying to take care of themselves I
have gleaned from watching all of you
engage with knowledge and commitment to
make sure that our high quality
information remains trusted and
available to all
and I've learned how we Embrace new
technologies and new approaches to
enrich our 200 year old history with new
strategies new ways of accomplishing our
mission
I've learned an awful lot I now know
what curation is I understand network
security better and I know what it takes
to create a library collection that is
both preserved as well as disseminated
and open to the public
I have learned about flexibility and
creativity in the moment particularly as
we went through the three years of the
pandemic and never once stopped in the
delivery of the great products and
services that the nlm provides
and I hope through those learnings I
have been motivated and inspired and
developed humility and wonder at the
resources we have and the way we are an
engine for Discovery across the world
I wish you the best in your future
should you ever find yourself on the
eastern shore of Maryland do stop by my
home in Easton and let me know what
learnings and lessons you're gleaning
from this fantastic place we call the
National Library of Medicine